higher rated I think this person beat
Anna recently like like a few minutes
ago
uh
I think they're in chats
good luck
oh this is five four oh maybe I
shouldn't have accepted this
because this game could take a while
okay this will probably be the last game
before I hop on call
the you glad wrap
maybe I should have played this I don't
know
no I like blocking the d-pawn
let's play
should probably develop the bishop
someone purchased to an mq chessboard
lightweight for 39.95
so this is a very typical opening I've
had similar versions of this
over the course of my duck chess career
this move actually looks really
interesting
Knight F4 and then doc F3
so putting a lot of pressure against the
bishop
we might see like Bishop B5 and ducky 2.
Bishop D3
inclines of like Queen D5
so now I have to make sure my Bishop
isn't taken and white has to make sure
the queen isn't lost to be alive while
all this stuck theory is being created
and it's important to be grateful
welcome back to gondriata
yeah I have a lot of uh attacking
potential here
oh
I think that's a mistake
but how
okay so I'm gonna play this is a given
now it's a question where to put the dot
because I can block H1 G1
or each one or G2 but I think the best
square is actually
wait a minute I could take the queen too
but I think I'm winning the queen
regardless
after this move
and essentially what's going to happen
the king will have to move to this
diagonal and the duck will be double
pinned
so the king and the Queen
and then consequently white will have to
lose a queen
so that's a really nice coctic
yeah oh no White's Queen
that's just a free Queen too
and then I'll play
actually don't know where to put the
duck
what's my next move
or what's White's next move
in Duck F3
venting the knight from coming back
I am losing this Knight but I think it's
okay
because now something like
Queen H5 and then duck G2
it's almost duck mate
the duck's gonna have to go to H4 next
move
foreign
but it can be very tricky to finish off
games
in Duck chess
okay now G5
I get the g-pawn rolling
and maybe
maybe this again
idea G4
yeah
I have to play this
so G2 is still a nice word because I'm
taking away
the night move and the king move
but not that King moves let's play this
wait what why can't I move
did I do something
also it looks like my e-pawn is like off
pixel do people see this
like the epon is
that's so weird
wait let me refresh
okay that was really weird okay keep on
just was refusing to move
I'm not sure what happened there
is no duck in the way unless there was
an invisible duck
I'll fix it with glue
yeah when in doubt
I should buy some glue
okay so the plan is to try and attack
the oh I should have played Queen H
when each four legal no the duck was on
the H file okay this is duckmates Queen
H4 duck G2 and the reason why no it's
not duckmates white light can escape
this
it's really close to duckmates yeah King
here and
ah okay let's play this and then duck G2
so I'm still targeting the king
the king will have to move here
is a very powerful Concept in Duck chess
to put the duck on a square where you
know the opponent will have to move it
away from that square
so I'm going to do this again
with this and this
it's really close to duckmates
and yeah there you should really be a
term for this like Duck Chuck
there's also the concept of like Duck
zooang
where the opponent has to stealth
self-destruct by moving the duck
self-deduct
I want to play F5
it's actually really frustrating that's
Queen side Castle primary duck
oh can I get a castle made in Duck chess
maybe I want queenside Castle
but I think that's easy let's let's just
play Rook d8 preserving King's eye
castling and then I'll move the duck
um maybe here
preventing the Bishop from developing
so this is the threat and this is a
threat
and the duck cannot stop both rats
oh that's fancy
so I can play this and then duck D7
ensuring my king is safe
what if we see King E5 Dugout 4
I should really throw in C6 if I get a
chance
or freaking okay
it's possible just to hang the king in
this game
that was a fun game
I should also note like one fun fact
after
oh I guess it doesn't really apply to
this position but let's say my opponent
played this and then let's say like this
if I wanted to I could Castle kingside
there's actually no official
like concept of check in this game even
though there's a concept of attacking
the king
um
the way casting works is you you can
Castle when in check you can Castle
through check
you can even Castle into check but
that's usually not a good idea
so
anyway
um thanks for the game
also thanks for the rating points